Gold, lava, plasma, some type of fluid going over and around the craft.
What is it that you saw and found out and can tell us about?
I only came for them because I sincerely believed they were going to die.
Sucks.
I think what we are dealing with is very, very, very old.
I think old humans have written those down in religious stories.
I think that it's quite clear that we have been influenced by something else.
I provided three rudimentary drawings, one of which was unclassified and the other two
were immediately thrown into a sap.
And the two that were thrown into a sap prove we are not alone.
In this episode of Weaponized, you will notice that we chose to censor certain details within
Dylan's testimony, most unrelated to UAP.
This is to avoid unauthorized disclosures and is subject to an ongoing clearance review.
Dylan was given
an unauthorized disclosures and is subject to an ongoing clearance review.
Only six days to prepare his testimony for Congress.
He is currently seeking clarity on being able to publicly discuss
certain aspects of his professional experience.
What is it that you saw and found out and can tell us about?
Well, we can go into it.
I don't know how much is going to come out.
Okay, let's hear it and then we'll figure it out later.
So basically, hypothetically speaking, let's say that I claim I saw Bigfoot running around
Nevada test range and I saw Bigfoot outside the Starbucks and Bigfoot was wearing a
U.S. Air Force uniform.
If I said that to Arrow or to the IG, but mainly Arrow, and Arrow comes back and says,
and I draw a nice picture of Bigfoot in a pretty Air Force uniform.
Let's say Arrow comes back and says, hey, Dylan, you're talking about Starbucks is unclassified.
You're talking about Bigfoot in that military uniform.
That's TS, no foreign.
You are never to say another word about that.
That's what Arrow did to me.
And they classified everything I brought forward.
So you're working for BAE and for somebody else.
Yep.
For somebody else in the structure of.
Multi-agency special access program.
Yes, sir.
And it's under the umbrella of a private company.
The private company is how they are getting us to work there.
But it is all under the umbrella of that agency.
The information you had about these flying Tic Tacs that people are taking down.
Do you get that information through your work at BAE?
There were people who ended up working there with me,
who were brought into the legacy program, whose lives were also destroyed.
And they believe based off of what I was saying about what I experienced in my life,
the triangle, what I knew that to be true at that point, they believe I was read into the program.
And they believe that because I was having the clearance issues and the VA issues and
everything else, the financial, what they did to me, they were experiencing it too.
And there were multiple people who I was.
I was working with that were a part of what is conveyed as a legacy program.
So you're working at BAE for an agency and on a coffee break or a smoke break,
you convert with your coworkers and you tell them about something
you've seen and they start sharing information with you.
Yes, but not even all that openly because people were still so freaked out about it.
And this gets into something else, which is when I was there and this is why
you know, we talked to Dave, um, and I explained this to Dave.
Correct.
Yep.
I, one of the things that was very odd was, you know, you're working 12 hours and it's
middle of the night, three in the morning after working a 12 hour shift, fourth day in the row,
you're just doing anything to stay awake.
I remember you were talking about UFOs and you talk about everything from football,
the baseball, the movies to music.
It's just, you're trying to stay awake.
You're trying to get through the night or the day.
And we were talking about UFOs.
Yeah.
And Bob Lazar come up and you're just talking normal talk.
And I remember I had talked about what I knew to be true.
And I had gotten a pop-up message on my computer.
It said, you know, you're not supposed to be talking about this to this day tech to this day,
aside from having gone to the IG and what was conveyed to me by my attorney.
To this day, technically I have never gone in an official Dylan.
Here's what's happening.
Do not do this.
Here's why it has been the subliminal pot shots.
But there were more multiple people that I was working with that were well aware of the reality
of this subject and considering where I worked, the finances that went into there and how much
money funneled through there and how many programs we touched, that there were a number of people
that were well aware of the reality of this situation.
The UFO subject had been a part of quote unquote legacy programs had gone the TV wise had done it.
But most of the people that were aware that were,
most of them were younger.
Most of them had had their careers destroyed, their lives destroyed.
Most of them believe that me talking about what I was dealing with, with my clearance and all
their problems, I was dealing with the company and the agencies.
They thought it was safe to talk to me about their own experiences in the legacy program.
They assume you knew more than you were saying.
100%.
So it's almost like, it sounds like they put all the bad eggs in one basket.
It's like, you know, all the, these guys.
These guys knew too much and they're blabbing.
We'll put them all over here with you.
Uh, pretty much.
I that's.
And was there surveillance of the employees?
How did the information go to a higher up that would send you a message says shut the hell up?
I mean, you're on an ops floor and you know, you have people from every agency you
can think of in there and you're on computer systems that are closed access and there's
government employees and contract employees from multiple different contract companies.
And.
Knowing what I know now at, in hindsight, knowing the way that.
These legacy programs work.
If you're not embedded in the company or coming as a government representative, it's TD wise.
And knowing the government has TDY requirements, depending on what agency you work for.
Some of these people probably found their way over the TDY.
And they had heard me talking about things that, uh, they.
Thought they were far more important than they really are and thought that I shouldn't be talking.
About it.
You're just bullshitting with coworkers pretty much just talking and they are with you.
Is there somebody in there that's counterintelligence that was sent in there to see who's clapping?
I would towards the later end.
I would bet.
So towards the later end, I would bet.
So at that point, you're not filing reports or calling New York times or raising hell.
No, I, to be honest with you, George, uh, talking to the media was so ingrained into me and other people in the work we did that it was like persona non grata.
Like if you want to talk to anybody outside.
Like you're a dead man.
You wouldn't have done it.
No.
I mean, even whenever I felt that I had to, I was shaking.
Um, even when I went to Senate, when I went to Congress, I was shaking.
Is this why your clearance was sort of put in limbo?
It doesn't exist because you're saying things you shouldn't be talking about.
Oh, I think early on it was a mistake.
And I talked with Dave brush about this.
I think early on, it was a mistake.
They were notified six, seven months into it.
And then from then on, they were.
They outright just did not care.
They terrorized me.
I mean, I would go into work.
They were notified by multiple companies that they were not housing my clearance correctly.
Multiple companies try to pick me up.
Multiple companies said they would give me a pay raise, a better job.
I couldn't take any of it.
They notified BAE, they filed complaints and I got the runaround between the company, the
two agencies that I work for.
Um, but long story short, it is my opinion in hindsight and other people who are also
whistleblowers.
And other people have worked in these programs.
That is a standard operating procedure by these people to keep this quiet.
Your career has been in classified programs.
Your trainees have been in classified programs.
They now tell you, you don't have a clearance.
You can't go to work anywhere else.
You are frozen here.
Whether you like it or not.
Yup.
16 hours a day doing light shift weekends, holidays for $62,000 a year.
But to be clear, you, you had a clearance.
It's not like they said you don't have one.
You lost it.
They're keeping it in a purgatory, which is a technique we've heard over and over of how
to keep people somewhere and, and almost like try to squeeze them out through pressure.
So I just want to make that clear.
It's not like he ever had anything, a mark on his record where they're like, you no longer
have a clearance.
He was in good standing.
It's a, it's a type of purgatory people create.
So look, um, we're kind of glossing over this idea.
We're here to talk about the UAP reality.
Boom.
You see something at Langley air force base that you have testified to arrow.
To Congress is set intelligence.
You to even people that we're not talking about, you've testified to a lot of people
officially I CIG you, you wanted them to know that this craft you saw, which you're thinking
maybe look, maybe it's something we reverse engineered.
We now know through our, that it's likely not just our tech, that it might prove David
crushes ideas about reverse engineering that we've been told all the way back from Lazar.
He saw an operational craft over a military installation.
Yeah.
Which is far beyond.
There's no fingerprint for, we don't have that technology to the best of my understanding
at this time.
So now whose was it?
Was it a joint operation where the comms with whoever the pilots were, but it was a huge
triangle that had this electrostatic charge.
The other thing you told me that like, I want to hear more about was the gold glow, because
I've heard this over and over and over like a lava lamp.
It was, it was a sort of undulating on the skin of this thing, right?
Like a.
Basically.
Yeah.
The best way I can describe it is overlay.
If you're working at a lava lamp and seeing that flow, place a yellow semi-transparent
lava lamp flow on this craft, making 90 degree turns and all over the craft.
And it's just this yellow transparent, almost like smoke cloud pulsating all around the
craft.
So clearly a technology like, like Matthew Brown has kind of thought that either it's
like it's non-human intelligence technology.
Or it's something that we've figured out how to operate.
And it's like a breakaway civilization.
It's so advanced that this is something that's not acknowledged even to Congress, the people
that should have oversight.
So you've got that big one UFO experience, right?
The UAP experience.
Then you have this accidental exposure, but to such a high degree, I don't want to ask
the question because I don't know if you can answer, but did you physically see photos?
Did you physically see these documents?
No.
But.
Yeah.
I mean, I think that they were talking to me in relay that the individuals that had
related, they were doing so because they were genuinely concerned for their life because
their careers were taken, their houses were broken into.
I mean, computers taken mailboxes gone through that.
And again, they knew what I was going through at this time.
They had given me enough information and the agreement was that if they died, that I run
with it and just blow the whole thing off.
So.
Yeah.
I mean, that's, that's an experience of this tech.
But then this is something George, we, and I hear a lot, which is in the legacy when
you're kind of put into the bad camp, you know, you're, you're, you're under scrutiny
now that there are, there are these people that are threatening you and you do feel afraid
for your life and we'll get to it, but there are some things that occurred to you as this
gets kind of deeper and deeper with what's happening.
But just to be clear, so you're in a place where there's some sort of purgatory going
on.
Everybody has clearance, but they're in this sort of purgatory, you're in the sort of purgatory,
right?
And then, uh, people direct directly involved the legacy program are afraid for their lives.
So they're telling you so that you can at least somebody at their level can take that
information if something bad happens to it.
I think it's, it was, it was definitely that, but it was also, this is such an isolating,
lonely experience, especially for young people to, to be exposed to the reality of this.
If you, if you already don't have the acknowledgement that it's a possibility.
Like.
If you're, I don't want to say close minded.
If you're average Joe Blow going through life and then all of a sudden this pops up on your
radar and you're seeing physical proof of it, you probably take a step back and go well.
So you have that aspect, then the same people have that aspect of it.
And they also have the aspect of their government destroying them.
So they are going through the same thing.
You are.
Exactly.
Their clearances are in limbo, home break-ins threats.
Uh.
But when I had come into contact with these people, they had had to resign from their
government position and take a contracting job for less money.
They were basically blacklisted for six months.
The only reason they ended up getting a job was because somebody on the legacy program
had hooked them up after six months and they ended up where I was at.
And they heard me talking all this stuff and they're like, oh, you ended up here too, buddy.
So, uh, what the hell is going on here?
It's like the island of bad toys or something like that.
You know, put them all in one basket.
After I saw what I saw and I've experienced what I've experienced, I kinda, I think most
of us have taken the delve into all of this material and you're like, I know this is true.
I know this is true.
Who else is saying these true things?
Who else is relaying information that I know to be true to try and make sense of your own
life?
Um, they were aware of what I was talking about.
I don't know the capacity in which they were.
Yeah.
They were briefed in there's things that I knew that these people were aware of it.
Even they would not say, um, one of those being biologicals, you think there's a storehouse
of that information that anybody would have put something away in case something bad happened
to him.
But do you know what happened to these people?
You know, the ones that I know still continue in the government, um, I think they, they
continue to classified operations programs.
They're not coming forward.
They would never come forward a million years.
Unless they were going to die.
And that's, it really sucks for me coming forward because I only came forward because
I sincerely believe they were going to die.
Sucks.
And you yourself have had, um, really unfortunate coincidences, we'll put it that way.
And that's one of the reasons why we started communicating was because if anything did
happen to him, he wanted to make sure some journalists like you and me knew about it.
And so I call that like a perceived threat or a real threat.
I don't know.
And I think some people too.
Yeah.
I mean, it's hard to put your finger on the cause of it.
I know that happened with David Gresh, with Matthew Brown, you know, you can have police
reports saying this happened, I had a break into my home, but proving who did it, even
though it's very coincidental timing.
And you have one of those experiences yourself was right when, um, you're, you're leaving
this agency that you're not naming that I think we're all guessing, but right when you're
leaving that employment, yeah, I mean, I can fill you in there.
That's a good time for that one.
So for three and a half years, I worked for BAE without the ability to take another job.
And the nature of the work we did, we would get a new boss, whether a contractor or Gavi
every six months.
I mean, that was the way it was.
People were in and out of there.
Cause that job is hell.
Three and a half years into it, we get a new contractor boss and he comes in and does the
typical Dylan's line.
His clearance is fine.
He doesn't have his master's degree.
He's full of crap.
And I'm like, I'm done with this, my man.
So I went to the office.
I went to my government employee at the time who I thought I was friends with.
Um, and I told him, I was like, I want to know who your boss is.
Cause I'm going to his office right now, seven o'clock in the morning.
I'm telling him I want my stuff fixed.
He tried to tell me, don't do it.
It's going to look bad.
I was like, I've been here for three and a half years.
I cannot do this anymore.
This work is killing me.
This is insane.
This is the worst place on planet earth.
And I go to his boss and I walk in there.
I say, here's my name.
Here's my social.
Look me up in J past and scattered.
Castles.
Cause I guarantee I'm not in there.
And verbatim, he says to me, he says, there's no way you want to be allowed in the building.
I was like, do you want to bet?
He looks me up and he says, oh, wow.
You haven't had a clearance since 2014.
He gets on a, I give him other names of people who were in similar situations.
Uh, and he gets on a phone call and he makes a call and he says, fix this now.
I walk out of the building and magically my clearance plots up in J past and scattered
castles that morning.
I get a phone call from BAE system security.
And they're.
Not happy with what I did.
I take the first job I can, which was doing teaching counter UAS.
So counter, I'm into aerial surveillance vehicles at Jido, which became DITRA.
And uh, long story short, I come into work a couple of weeks later and I say, here's
my two week notice.
I'm out of here.
They were like, oh, well, what can we do to keep you?
I was like, there is absolutely nothing you can do to keep me.
They're like, all right.
They're like, you got out process well before two weeks I'll process in a few days I go
and I.
I'll process early.
And as soon as I signed the paperwork, I rock walk out of the office and the company
that hired me, uh, contacts me and they say, your clearance has been erased again.
So I lose my clearance in may.
That's may of 2018.
Uh, the company that hired me went to their prime, which was at that point, khaki CACI.
And for about a month they are working, at least they're telling me they're working on
getting my clearance fixed.
And in early mid June, I am contacted by the company that hired me.
And they said.
We are unable to get your clearance back in the system.
We have to move on to other candidates.
Good luck out there.
Uh, we don't think you're ever gonna get your clearance fixed.
That night I was invited out, uh, and I was getting ready to sell my vehicles.
I had pulled my 401k at this point because I knew I was done.
I had filed for unemployment, which they denied me for.
And on the way home, I told my car and there was a police investigation and the police
had told me in confidence that my brake lines were cut.
They wanted it to look like a suicide, which goes into what the VA was doing with me and
the medical issues and the doctors that are resigned and all that.
So you leave somewhere you were at next thing, you know, you're pushing your, your
brake to the floor, total the car, but you're able to get home and you get home.
And then of course the police see the car totaled and they either wonder, were you sober?
Is everything okay?
And you invite them over.
We said, come do a breathalyzer.
Yup.
They said, well, this is going to take a while.
Um, we're going to contact you tomorrow.
And then the lead investigative officer in that case physically comes to your home and
warns you that somebody tried to kill you.
Your brake lines were cut.
He verbatim said, the only reason I'm not charging you with a crime is because your
brake lines were caught.
I'm not charging for a crime because your brake lines were cut.
Is there a police report?
There is a police report of the total car and there's a police report of what I said
to the officer, which is I went out with a friend who worked for the agency.
I had two, three drinks playing pool.
Over the night.
Had some wings on the way home.
Car totaled.
Does it say in any police report your brake lines were cut?
I have been searching for it.
No.
And this is what sucks is this is the most damning and I know what was said to me.
And this is the only thing out of all the craziness that I do have evidence to that
you guys have seen these weird, uh, polygraph tests and VA tests and all this, but the police
report verbatim saying that my brake lines were caught.
I am still trying to get proof of.
Exactly.
This is the undercut thing, right?
It's like, it's like, you know, we can talk about the administrative terrorism, the bizarre
psychological, I'd say experiments that he had to endure.
You're working for BAE, but not really.
You're working.
That's the structure of this company.
You're working for an agency.
It's doing the same stuff.
Yup.
It's called redacted.
I mean, you have covered positions, non-official cover positions.
And even then I'm starting to float down a river of classification and classified information.
But basically I was.
Yeah.
I was from BAE.
Yes.
Is there, are there other people who aren't necessarily BAE government people that you
are interacting with at any 100% and there's other agencies outside of the IC that I'm
interacting with.
There are other contractors I'm interacting with because it's a way to redacted.
Here's my question is your employer and the secret employer know what, you know, they
know what you did.
You've done it well, even though you feel guilty about it, um, why wouldn't they take
care of you?
Yeah.
They're not going to spill beans or go off the deep end.
So why wouldn't they do that?
All right.
Now you're asking me my opinion and this is my opinion to be clear.
I think at the time that all of this was happening and considering with what the VA was doing
to me, what was on my official record, it is my opinion that it would have been very
easy to discredit me publicly by saying this individual is delusional.
Look at all his medical records.
Uh, he's a disgruntled employer.
He's an employee, a liar, all of that.
And then the problem became though, especially when I came to Aero and spilled the beans
and then people found out I kept police reports and voicemails that are on my phone.
You guys have heard that people found out very quickly that it was going to be very
easy to discredit me when I was still under the belief that if I said anything, they were
to call me a Looney Tune.
Yeah.
I found out how much I knew what I could prove and what I had and it quickly became a problem
of he is a danger.
We need to deal with this guy.
Yeah.
Bob Lazar kind of a hundred percent.
And that's the thing that, you know, that I noticed a lot is that a lot of what the
types of reprisals that you have experienced in your line of work mimic the same tactics
all the way back to 1989 when George was reporting on Bob Lazar.
Um, it's like.
It's like just a ways to discredit you and, and put you at, and look, I, I've seen all
the evidence that you've provided.
We've looked through it.
I've talked to people that know you really well over these years.
Um, you're a solid individual or wouldn't be sitting here.
So the, the fact that they're setting up the option to be able to discredit is exactly
what, why they probably chose Bob compared to him.
I mean, he's working official capacity with clearances and all that stuff, but it's the
same tactics.
Yeah.
It's all a standard operating procedure.
I actually laugh.
I mean, honestly, I was laughing about George's monk right here when confronted, uh, one thing
about the United States government is they don't really change your SOPs or TTPs.
They think if it works, it's going to work forever.
And this goes back to issues we were talking about, which is the internet changed the game.
AI is going to change it more and too many people have come out.
So these SOPs and TTPs to keep whistleblowers silent, you really got to start adapting.
Unfortunately.
And I don't want to give.
Yeah.
I don't want to give away the secret or, uh, ammunition, but this is a different ballgame
this time.
Do you have a sense of how they've made your life miserable as a result of you leaving
that job and really setting the table for discrediting you if they need to do it?
I mean, okay, that works.
Um, for example, I witnessed a suicide.
The police showed up.
Uh, there was an official police report.
I was with other veterans.
The veterans affairs administration was contacted.
And the police contacted the veterans.
I contacted the VA on my behalf to tell the psychologist there that this happened.
I went in with another veteran, a Marine who deployed Afghanistan combat engineer.
Great guy.
We went into our, uh, psychological eval from the suicide.
We both witnessed together.
Uh, he was treated with due respect, asked how he felt, apologize a whole nine.
Uh, what they did to me is they accused me of faking a police report, faking being a
police officer wrote in my official medical records, which have hindered me to this.
It's still ongoing that I am a liar.
I am prone to delusions.
I make everything up and that is in my official medical records.
You guys have the police report number.
You guys have the voicemail.
I played it for you both.
That was the first thing the VA did to me.
Uh, I was put into a hypnosis biofeedback program where once a week I had to go to the
VA and I would be hooked up to a polygraph machine and they would flash images of an Afghan.
Afghan child with a gun to a butterfly.
And I'm hooked up to this polygraph machine and I have to count backwards from a hundred
by seven while they're flashing images.
And if I got the number wrong, like 193 86 and I said 77, they'd start screaming at me,
honking an air horn and I'd have to restart.
Um, I had to pull my 401k cause I didn't have a clearance.
I couldn't get a job.
I almost lost my house.
I had to fight BAE.
And the agencies I worked for for unemployment, which was $270 a week in Northern Virginia,
which if you know anything about Northern Virginia is the richest part of America.
It is not feasible to even get groceries off of that.
Basically I lost everything but my house.
And at one point in time, because I was concerned, I was going to lose my house because I am
a 10% disabled vet.
The VA is denying I ever did the jobs I did denying I have the issues I have the whole
nine.
I was genuinely concerned I was going to lose my house.
And I began to honestly consider and look at nonviolent offenses in order to have three
hots in a cot because I was very quickly approaching the point in time where I would probably be
a homeless disabled vet.
So I don't think they wanted you to kill yourself.
That is 100% what they did.
In fact, there was a doctor who filed a complaint within the IG at the VA on my behalf because
they were in his opinion, trying to get me to kill myself at one point in time, they
put me on.
I prescription medication for PTSD and depression, which I wasn't allowed to collect by the way
the VA still denied I had PTSD or depression, but they put me on the medicine for it.
And I woke up in the middle of the night while on this medication and the best way I can
describe it is you know, you need to relieve yourself to go to the bathroom or you're thirsty.
It's a physical response.
I woke up in the middle of night and the physical response in my brain was commit suicide.
I freaked out rightfully so something I will never do is commit suicide or Roman Catholic
it is against my religion.
I'm going to do so I contacted the VA.
I went to the VA on the police's again all documented and the VA psychologist who was
a CIA employee of all things, or was was, you know, said, Oh, this is common, you need
to increase your dose.
The psychiatrist, you have his name Yeah, he was made aware he filed a complaint on
my behalf.
He found out there was a team dedicated to me at the VA.
And he filed a complaint.
Against that team.
He was told that he is nothing's going to change that I answer them.
And he told me verbatim, he said, Dylan, you need to do everything in your power to live
through this.
What they are doing to you is wrong.
Do not trust any of these doctors, there is something very wrong with what is being done
to you.
And keep in mind this whole time this is happening.
I'm over at this at BAE.
And he resigned in protest to resigned because of what they were doing to Dylan and let's
just back up.
This is some stranger things.
This is bullshit.
To take somebody like Dylan through, I think it was Stanford research, right to take somebody
through like Dylan.
Penn State and Stanford.
It was what?
And, you know, use Aeroforms and these violent images.
And, I mean,
Malcolm McDowell.
It is.
It's my favorite movie.
Yeah, it's like Clockwork Orange, not to make light of it, but like, you know, I've talked
to a bunch of people about this.
And there's it's some sort of psychological program that has really deep ties within the
CIA.
MK Ultra.
And it's it's like a continuation of that is what I understand that.
So there's something else going on that Dylan is searching for answers.
And I get that with what with what he's experienced.
It appears to be connected to the UAP thing.
I mean, I'm almost certain it is because this goes back to when I was discharged from the
Air Force.
After I'll process with the VA and the Air Force, the DOD mandated I go to the Navy.
I'm not in.
I never work with them.
I train Navy guys, but I'm not Navy.
I never work for the Navy other than Special Ops.
Which is under redacted.
I had out process with the Navy.
And when I went down out process with the Navy in 2013, I go down there and the Navy
doctor is asking me about ESP, God, remote viewing, aliens, the whole nine.
You walk in on that day.
I walk in and during my out process for my medical discharge, you're like, how's your
back?
Oh, we're sorry about your dental thing.
We'll get that taken care of.
Oh, by the way, you know, we have some psychological questions to ask you.
Do you believe in God?
Do you believe in ESP?
And this is that's the thing.
That's the thing.
That's the first time George, the second time I had the same thing happen to me when
I was filing for PTSD with the VA, the VA doctors and the clinician that did it.
The psychiatrist who did my VA eval started asking me, oh, do you believe in God?
Do you believe in ESP remote viewing?
Has this ever happened to you?
Do you have prophetic dreams?
Did you ask him?
Why are you asking me this?
I did.
And they're like, oh, well, this is just standard eval and, and all of this stuff.
And this is what's so troubling is because I'm doing this.
And it leads us all the way to now and why I'm here on camera with you is I did everything
by the book for our country.
I put my faith in bureaucrats and companies in our nation.
And what I got for it was losing everything.
No job, no clearance.
My master's degree gone.
My reputation in the toilet.
I don't put a bullseye on my back with arrow the IG.
I tell Congress, let's get it straight.
Congress knows like everybody can play the games.
I'm sorry to the congressional staff and members that are here listening to this.
Y'all know.
Well, in, in fact, it's people within government that vouched for the authenticity
of your character and experiences that have reached out to me and George and, you know,
they're a little nervous of us, like covering, you know, what it is that you have to talk
about.
Although there's a big thing you can't talk about.
And I respect that.
I understand as a Patriot, you know, and the fact that you've testified to, to, to that
stuff that you can't talk about it.
But I guess my question is, I mean, do you think just right on the nose, man, do you
think that you've been part of some like current day MK ultra type experimentation on you based
on a related to UAP or not?
And is it punishment for what you've seen or is it part of the whole process you were
meant to?
What I will say is this, and this can be, I hope not, but I suspect so.
Could you walk us through at what point you start seeking out other people who've been
through the same thing or, and your attempts to share information with agencies that are
supposedly honestly investigating this?
That's a great question, sir.
And I love it.
So I get out, um, all this weird stuff is happening to me.
Clearance gone, pull my 401k, fight for unemployment, the whole nine.
In October or November of 2018, I get a phone call from somebody out of CENTCOM working
for Khaki and he says, Hey, my name is insert name.
Okay.
What happened to you?
What they did to you was wrong.
I'm going to send you paperwork and get your clearance fixed immediately.
You have to promise me though, that when you get your clearance fix, we're going to go
work back for the government and a point in time will come where you're going to have
to go and make some decisions.
That was a conversation I had.
I was like, yeah, sure.
Sounds great, man.
Whatever you say.
Make some decisions.
What?
What does he just said?
Go back to the government.
Uh, do what you've been doing.
Be a standup guy.
And you know, life is.
It's going to take you interesting places.
Does that sound like come back in and shut the hell up or what?
Sounds like it, but I don't know.
At this point, I'm just trying to keep a roof over my head.
So you're thinking, yeah, I said, yeah, he sends me a contract to deploy to Afghanistan
to do security for $40,000 a year.
He says, don't worry about the pay.
Don't worry about the job.
Just sign the contract.
Sounds great.
My man signed the contract, send it back three months later in December, January, he calls
me up.
He's like, Hey, your clearance is good to go.
Everything's fine.
You can't deploy to Afghanistan.
Good luck, buddy.
So he was doing that just to get your clearance reinstated.
That was a 100%, uh, somebody just trying to take care of you on the inside.
So from there I got hired back to Jido, uh, the job I had taken teaching and training
counter UAS ops, uh, was gone.
They hire me to go do all source and target dev.
So basically, you know, you take pictures and you have strings going everywhere, companies
and names and location.
That was me.
I was doing all that for ops.
Get in there.
And this is 2019 and I am keeping my head down trying to get my finances in order, keep
my head down, but I'm still paying attention.
I'm paying attention to the chat coming through work.
I'm paying attention to reporting.
I can read.
I'm paying attention to you guys.
I'm paying attention to what's on public media, lose names out there, a tip all SAP.
I'm looking at everybody sideways.
Like I don't trust anyone.
Um.
Um, and then all of a sudden 2022 rolls around and this is where everything kicks off again
for me.
2022 rolls around and, uh, the task force becomes known to me at least.
And I'm paying attention to our space and that forum, and I'm kind of participating
in the forum and I'm pulling data from the forum that I know is 100% true and people
from the legacy program.
And I'm putting in little pieces myself.
I'm putting myself in there to put people on the right track under your name, under
my name.
Yup.
And I'm paying attention to the chat rooms and that'll target you immediately.
We know that that our space was infiltrated 100% and it was the same with chat surfer.
I'm in chat surfer.
And here's the story.
It's a hell of a story to 2022 rolls around in the fall of 2022, somebody who was interviewed
by the task force and claimed to be a whistleblower has this big shin dig and people are talking
about going and people are reaching out to me.
I'm like, I'm not going anywhere near that.
That is CIA, CI and CIA central.
You guys are crazy doing it.
And you know, people had known my background, knew I, my masters, I was trying to shot my
resume, get a better job, but, uh, I don't go to it.
And a couple of people start bashing the UFO community.
And I post a response in there and I say, look, my man, you really think Marco Rubio,
who wants to be president is going to put his name to something unless he knows there's
truth there.
And immediately I start getting private messages from people, high ranking people overseas,
like special ops officers, like point on my man, like, you know exactly what's up.
And we formed this small little group and we're sending information to each other.
That's allowed legally to be shared in a group pops up and the same individual that had this
get together and makes a declaration that the people who worked in the legacy program,
their lives were in danger.
And you know, my background, you know, I did for a living, you know, what was done to me,
you know, my feelings about all of this.
And for the next hour after he made that declaration, I checked in with people who said they were
part of the task force and they said, we do believe that is accurate.
And I berated the individual who made that statement for over an hour and said, do not
lie to me about this.
I know you're lying about other things.
I, I was adamant.
Yeah.
I was adamant that the task force was going to have to come forward as a whistleblower
and I no offense to arrow.
I think arrow is doing the job they are told to do.
And I understand that you put 18, 20 years in the government, you want your pension,
you have a good house, you have kids and you know how dangerous the outside is, but they're
not doing the job.
The American constitution demands of them.
Would you say there are a difference between the OB task force at arrow?
I mean that the OB task force was had different motivations and in my limited interaction
with the task force.
And since it's been disbanded, yes, in my limited and the, and again, I don't want to
bash arrow.
I think there's a lot of great people at arrow.
I think they are doing what is best for them in their careers, not what's best for this
subject and humanity and the constitution.
Is it a mistake for you to have gone on to that space and engage with people?
You don't exactly know who they are.
You know that some of them are full of shit.
I won't know until this was all over.
I, because of the decisions I made after everything.
I had been through and looking out for people who were interested in this while also keeping
my eye on it to see where this was going.
If I help keep people, keep people safe or if three years from now, they actually do
a real disclosure.
Then yeah, it was a good decision.
This space thing that we're talking about, is there any security protection for it?
Is it in any way on a platform that's not available to general public?
Yeah.
You have to have the proper clearances.
You're engaging with other whistleblowers, insiders that you think are.
I'm sure there were other insiders and whistleblowers because there are things that I came across
that I had made comments about in the moment that I had pointed it out, those people disappeared
and that information was pulled.
You know that some of the information is right.
Some of it not so dependable or reliable.
You're not spilling any beans there.
You kind of give people a nudge in the right direction or something.
Yeah.
I mean, mainly when I stuck to was I stuck to.
When I experienced it.
You know, that I was.
I was going through this whole thing.
I mean, I was so focused on it.
I was going to be like, I'm going to have to do this.
I was going to have to leave it.
I was going to do that.
I was going to be like, I'm gonna do this.
And then I got to talk to Langley.
Oh, you did tell all this, I had talked about Langley.
And then I talked about a little bit about all the things that had happened in my life.
Um, and it was in part because I was very concerned that people were being given false
information purposefully.
And I was also very concerned that people who were interested in this subject and had
experiences of their own were about to put themselves in grave danger.
Like grave danger.
Anyway, his name was discussed on a UFO UAP small-time podcast, and that individual you talk about threw a shit fit, excuse my language, and they started making accusations that were not true.
Friends of mine were given documents to sign to try and have that individual who was on that podcast job revoked, insider threat, the whole nonsense.
I got tangled up in it because there were things that I was pointing out that were intelligence products that were not real, and somehow those intelligence products were leaked onto Twitter, and I had just dropped a message like,
Anybody find this weird that this product that just came out today is being discussed by...
debunkers two days prior.
All of a sudden, that individual is threatening me.
How dare you don't make those accusations?
And I'm like, I work for this agency.
I know what the product is.
There's no way you're making that claim, and there's no way what their assessment is is valid.
It's insane.
Long story short, everything got kaput because of...
I don't know the true reason why.
I know that they had a hand in it.
Somebody took control of that discussion group.
Oh, yeah.
Who seemed...
There seemed to be motives that might be counterintelligence kind of a thing, or...
Oh, I'm sure, and I can...
I'm positive of this as well.
There are people in there that are so anti-UFO, UAP, that come from very interesting agencies and very interesting locations, and the comments that they put in that chat room somehow are reflected by people on Twitter right now, like, verbatim.
Like, I go into work, and I see a statement, and I come out of work, and on Twitter is same statement, just saying a little odd.
Okay.
There's a direct mirror of on inside the intelligence community in a classified realm, and those statements are then echoed onto X...
Oh, yeah.
...within the same day.
24, 48 hours, but whatever they're claiming up in there, their little argument...
...to influence the public debate on UAP.
Oh, yeah.
So there is a direct line of intelligence community interaction on X.
And public perception, yeah.
And public perception.
Now, whether or not those people are paid, I can...
It doesn't matter.
There's a lot of motivation.
100%.
Yeah.
That's what I'm saying, but I know that that is being done.
Seen it a bunch more lately.
So you engage with this group.
You see some problems that have developed.
What's the next step for you?
The decision to share it with official agencies?
Yeah, here we go.
So that same individual, the gentleman, he makes a claim that people's lives are in danger.
I have been through hell and back.
I am trying to keep my head above water.
There are friends of mine that are engaging with this individual.
And I'm trying to warn them politely, hey, just be aware this isn't exactly true.
And people are now slowly, people who are very intelligent, smart people are very quickly realizing that I know what I'm talking about.
And that individual makes a statement that people's lives are in danger.
At the same time that statement is made, an individual that I knew that was in the legacy program lost their job for proprietary information sharing.
I did not want to hear that.
I did not want to go to Arrow first because I know that this is all true.
I know there's a program.
I know there are entities.
I know it.
I have experienced it.
It is what it is.
And I contact that individual, berate them for an hour.
And then finally I say, all right, I have to take your word for it.
I can't let anybody die.
That was my promise to the people I knew in the legacy program.
If they died, that I would come forward.
I don't want them to die.
So I come forward and I go to Congress.
First thing I do is I call, I get connected to Senate staffers.
And they are asking me questions.
And I tell them I have witnessed a triangle at Langley Air Force Base.
But I have direct, in-depth knowledge of a hell of a lot more.
And I am not comfortable sharing that over the phone.
And as long as I am legally allowed to come to you, I will be there as soon as you will let me.
And I go in to meet with staffers.
We know who you testified to.
And it's not, you know, it's somebody who has a high responsibility when it comes to this subject.
As far as intake and protecting whistleblowers.
And when that person was in position, which they're not anymore, they did a great job.
They did.
I wish nothing but the best for them.
And I love those people, all of them.
It upsets me.
And I had suspicions because I, again, have been through what I've been through.
And I can kind of recognize when people are being toyed with that towards the tail end, they were definitely being played with.
And that was my concern.
And I think they recognized I knew it.
And they tried to...
Yeah.
...alleviate it on me.
But I wish nothing but the best for them.
You told them pretty much everything?
Or did you hold some of it back?
I held a lot back.
I had gone in.
They had scheduled my meeting.
There were four of them in the room.
You gave them program names, locations, the nature of the propulsion systems, everything.
I gave them my direct knowledge of the triangle.
My direct knowledge of that entire event.
And then guaranteed factual...
No argument about it, a legacy program in detail with technology integration, how it works, where it's at, the whole kit and caboodle.
So they know.
What's the reaction?
How do they react?
Are they serious or are they...
Well, my two favorite moments is the one gentleman that we know was absolutely excited.
And he was very much like, it's like, okay, let me hear more.
Let me hear more.
There's another one.
There's another one that is public now who I don't think he really wanted to believe it.
And it made some comments here and there.
And then towards the tail end, I had dropped two magic words.
And when those two magic words dropped, I will never forget it.
As soon as those two words dropped, that individual's mouth hit the floor.
He threw his hands in his hair, looked at me, literally looked down at the paper he was writing notes on and exasperated an agency name and was just like staring off into space.
Like, what the hell am I...
What am I supposed to do now?
Was it a program name?
Yes.
Two word program name?
Yep.
Something you should not know.
Probably.
I mean, at this point it is what it is.
But that they, based on your reaction, they knew.
100%.
And this goes back to Arrow, cause after that it go to Arrow.
But, um, the questions they were asking me, they knew enough.
So like when you ask questions, if you ask certain questions in a certain order, you as the person being asked can figure
out.
You know, information already.
So during that questioning, the questions they were asking and the things they were saying, I actually, cause I didn't want them to think they were leading me on.
I would actually tell them, I will answer that in a moment.
Please do not ask that yet because you could technically be leading me.
Like I'm doing that while I'm briefing Senate staff.
And then I go over to house and I expose a hell of a lot more in house staff, which was not UFO related, but serious crimes.
I go to Senate.
I drop the information on them.
Uh, they.
And my impression quickly realized I know a heck of a lot of very, very, very important information.
And at that point there was a conversation that I overheard where they were talking about whether or not to bring me to house side due to safety concerns.
That was literally it.
And it was worried for you.
They were, yes.
Um, they had asked me, did I feel in danger?
And I did not want to tell them about everything else I'm telling you now, cause it sounds so insane.
I don't want to come across as insane.
But it's all true.
Is this in a skiff?
It was, it was in a skiff.
Uh, no, to my understanding, no recordings.
Did they say, Hey, we're going to have you come back.
They're talking about nobody to go see the house.
That they brought me in.
They said, did you go to arrow?
I said, I have no way to contact arrow.
And I want to talk with you guys first before I go to arrow.
Cause I have concerns with arrow knowing that they are not representing this issue fully.
So I go through the Senate staff.
They have the conversation about bringing me to house.
There is a gentleman in the house that they decided to bring me to who.
What I was informed of was he didn't really necessarily believe in all this, but he took safety seriously.
I was brought to the house side where I briefed a house staffer.
Um, and then we got into a heck of a lot of other non UFO things that are serious crimes that I was witnessed to people.
The, that American citizens would be furious if they found out we're in positions, they were in corruption, corruption, sexual harassment, people getting taxpayer funds.
That should.
Have been dishonorably thrown out of the military, the whole nine.
Um, and I told them, I told that individual and another who was present in the room that day about other things that are semi related to this.
And I told the individuals, I said, check all of it.
I guarantee it's all true.
And, uh, three weeks later, I get a phone call and they said, we want you to go to arrow as soon as possible.
Here's their email address.
And I said, verbatim, is it what the country needs?
Yes.
Do I go?
Go into everything.
And am I protected?
Yes.
And I said, all right, let's do it.
So I testified to Senate and house staff members.
I was told I shouldn't use testify.
I informed Senate and house staffers on March 3rd.
I went to arrow either March 27th or March 28th of 2023.
And I went to arrow, um, and went through that whole process with them.
Um, the gentleman I met with.
Uh, one was a DOD officer.
The other was an FBI agent.
They were pleasant.
Um, I think they were quite shocked of the information I gave them and things that were currently happening and how I could tie it to legacy programs and certain technologies and capabilities.
Um, but due to my severe concern for the protection of people, I did not want to disclose certain information.
And they wanted that.
I told them I wouldn't do it because I believe then that if that information was shared with arrow, those individuals would be targeted.
And then that became its whole issue later on when I got my classified arrow in the far MFR memorandum for record.
So it is what arrow is supposed to give to arrow witnesses.
Usually unclassified.
They classified mine and send it to my government email address, uh, where I had to print.
It off in front of the entire office.
I had to edit it first because there were mistakes in it, which I was told I needed to correct those mistakes.
And those mistakes I was concerned would reveal information.
I did not want to share.
So I had to make the corrections.
My arrow MFR clearly was targeting a specific staffer.
I made a note to make sure that they were misrepresenting the staffers intention and information that was discussed.
Basically this.
Um.
MFR was a fishing expedition by Arrow to try to pin something on somebody that he testified to that we know to try to make it look like they were doing something untoward.
So, yeah, they had an agenda for listening to your testimony.
It wasn't really about UFOs, UAP.
It was to, what can we use this for?
Probably both.
You know, this is my opinion.
I think that the two gentlemen I testified to are great Americans.
I think they actually care.
I think that this came from higher up.
I think I had conversations with the people, at least one of them that I testified to, I think is a good person who understands a hell of a lot more.
And I think that what they did to me came from on high.
So they were listening to your story.
They were, God damn.
Oh, yeah.
They were affected by what you're telling them.
Oh, yeah, they were.
And I was able to draw connections for them that clearly they had no idea that that was happening.
Is this under oath?
Or you had to sign something?
I told them.
I did have to sign my MFR, yes.
So I did sign that.
And that information was loosely in there.
But technically, I was not under oath.
Again, something that these attorneys that are in this program made sure to tell me that that was not under oath.
But I did sign an MFR, legally binding.
And subsequently, have you learned there are limitations on what you told them?
Is there limits on who else you can tell the same stuff to or anything like that?
I have no idea.
So no idea.
And we're getting right into the idea.
Oh, my gee.
Okay.
So go to Arrow, end of March.
Give them most of the information, what they need to know to know that this is very real.
This is happening, that people are being affected, that there are issues.
And about that summer, and I remember the day, it was the day that Donald Trump got indicted in Georgia.
The Gang of Eight was called into an emergency meeting.
And the only reason why I remember it, and I wish I knew the date.
But that day is the day that I made all the edits, printed off my MFR, signed it, and went in front of my entire office, re-scanned it back into my machine, and emailed it back to Arrow.
And that morning, the Gang of Eight was called into an emergency meeting about three hours after I sent it back to Arrow.
And that was the day Donald Trump was indicted.
I'm not saying they're correlated.
I just know it was that day.
Right.
So from there, I'm like, all right.
Well, they have my information.
So let's see what happens.
And, you know, during this time, I've been asked once or twice by people of importance whether or not I would testify to Congress under oath on this.
And I said without hesitation, yes.
Like, 100 percent, yes.
You testified to the operational UAP that you had direct, close proximity to, as well as the other aspect of what you came to understand about the legacy program, the reverse engineering, where it's housed.
The power source, what it looks like, including —
Redacted.
I would testify to anything and everything of importance to our congressional, to Congress, to the legislative branch.
I said it —
They should have oversight.
One hundred percent in having been the victim of crimes and having been through this whole thing and being a believer in the Constitution that this is all criminal, in my opinion.
They say they want whistleblowers.
They say they want people who haven't come public yet for this next hearing.
Yeah.
what they've said i know this is probably when or this comes out we'll be after that but that's
what they said they want you have been nominated to congress i have and you had additional
conversations with them with staff regarding the hearing that's coming he did all pre-vetting he
went through the whole process um i'm just curious why um immediately if you want whistleblowers to
talk this is their chance dylan would be a great chance just like matthew brown who you know and
our friends with you know it's nice to hear about immaculate constellation and have that document
put on congressional record but it's different than if they get to hear from him he'd be my
first pick with you for a hearing if i wanted real whistleblowers i appreciate it i tend to
agree if you're not going to bring home or bring out legacy guys but knowing what they did to me
for being an experiencer and having indirect exposure i can only imagine what they're going
through maybe there's a roadblock maybe well what you have to say is something that they
don't want out even with the task force well i tend to agree and we haven't even got to the icig
issue tell us about icig tell me about that all right so that summer i send off my aero mfr i've
been asked if i would testify under oath i say yes and all of a sudden i hear there's going to
be a ufo hearing i have no idea who's going to be there and all of a sudden dave grush is on my
computer screen at work and i'm like oh wow okay and dave is saying things like administrative
terrorism and a certain agency and certain
things and i am laughing to myself in the office i'm like that's me like i've been there done that
know that story know this um and dave says he has 40 witnesses and dave says he filed the ig
complaint and i'm like all right let's go dave did it maybe they're gonna actually do it maybe
you're gonna call all of us in here and do a full legislative hearing house and senate both chambers
let's hammer this out like
cia style we're reeling you guys back in do you assume you're one of the 40 witnesses he's
talking about at that time i did but i came to find out i wasn't yeah but you never testified
to david grush prior to 100 but you did not i did not no right so you would not be one of those
and that goes as to why i went to the ig okay so i i thought so because i've been through at that
point the only process i knew which was talk to congress talk to arrow i didn't know there was
this whole side again i'm like hiding out in my little bunker at
work like i am staying away from all this and i only peep my head out to like let people know
you should probably pay attention to this but also you are getting into some really dangerous
territory so i get a phone call after dave testifies and they uh notify me hey dylan we
want you to go the ig and i said all right what about they're like you know this stuff they mean
who congress uh a staffer and dave and an attorney that you guys are aware of i don't know if i can
say their name but an attorney you guys are aware of i i think just yeah that's good all right um
and they're like go the ig and i said am i safe is it what the country needs yes yes i
said all right let's make it happen and i go to the ig um that was in i want to say september
october i actually have the date for you guys if you need it um but i went there in 2023
late summer early fall of 2023 and i go through the ig process and to be on a
honest with you out of everything I really feel like the IG process was the worst I think the
people at Arrow genuinely cared but my opinion going through the IG and the questions they asked
me the things that were said to me made me feel like that was a fishing expedition and the only
thing they cared about was finding out how much I actually knew wow that is highly disappointing
it was very disappointing being in that room with the conversation and statements that were being
made to me like when somebody's at redacted asking you a question in the IG uh government employee
cuts them off and says you don't ask him that question and looks at me and tells me you don't
answer that question yeah whenever you when they ask you what do you want out of this and verbatim
direct quote on film by all means go get the uh recording because they said they recorded it
but uh they said what do you want out of this
and I said I want to look Congress in the eyes tell them the truth under oath so when I die I can
answer for this and know I did my job and the response was as far as we're concerned you already
did that and you're not doing it again so is this the actual inspector general or the ICIG
yes I have his card in my house you went through the whole thing I went through the whole thing
who else is there redacted so ICIG assistant director director redacted attorney on my right
so you try to do this right you go to ICIG and you literally feel like you're not doing the right thing
you're not doing the right thing you're not doing the right thing you're not doing the right thing
that they are just trying to pump you to figure out how much you know how dangerous you are to the
legacy program in my opinion looking back on this yes because the way they ask questions the
statements they made to each other the statements they made to me 100 seemed like they wanted to
find out how much I knew and at the end of this which you're aware the conversation I had with
the attorney it was you are credible not urgent you are not urgent you are not urgent you are not
go disappear in the winds leave this all behind shut up do not do anything you're in tie everything
you said which goes back to what we talked I mean I talked about my childhood in there I was told
everything I talked about in that room now is up for executive review and I brought up to the
attorney I talked about my childhood is that now up for it I talked about unclassified information
readily available on the internet and they said Dylan every single thing you talked about is now
subject to executive review do not go outside of those bounds your whole life pretty damn much
a great way to lock somebody down if you want to kind of intake their whole whistleblower story
what they know and then say now that you've testified to ICIG you have to walk away well
you realize they say that and that this has been in essence a waste of time that you walked into
sort of a trap I mean I can imagine how depressing it would be depressing it pissed me off because I
was already blacklisted from the IC and I told the attorney that I told
the IG that like I already know that there are things that are in place for me getting jobs
working in this field that years back are in play and it's happened to me since I got into the IG
which goes back to retaliation like technically I'm still being retaliated against inspector
general's office is there to hear about wrongdoing and things that shouldn't be happening in the
agencies that it oversees I you would think but this is now me being blackpilled and there's a
joke amongst all the military I'm not going to be blackpilled I'm not going to be blackpilled
I'm going to be blackpilled I'm not going to be blackpilled you're the DoD the IG isn't for you
the J is for the DoD the IG isn't for us the IG is for the government and that's the way I feel now
did you share this with the attorney who had been advising you about seeing these guys who
we're not saying who it is but who I think with the the client I think you're not supposed to do
that it's not like a big secret I'm just trying to be respectful I made it I made it aware to
them that the statement that he had made to me
was a grave concern. It made no sense. And I had asked, how do I do doctor? Because I do not trust
this process at all anymore. And basically from that point, I was completely shut out for over
a year, a year and a half. I think lawyers are trying to protect their clients. You know,
I don't think it's nefarious. I think that they're just trying to do or guide their client in what's
best for their wellbeing. Yeah. Well, especially somebody who has been around and knows what could
happen stuff. Yeah. That's unfortunate. Don't disagree. Um, so, you know, I go back to work.
I knew I was going to lose my job in the summer of 2024. And I started to ask questions. How do I
do doctor? Because I'm losing my job. I know I'm losing my job. I know I'm going to have a pain
trying to get a new job in the government. Nobody would really help me. And I'm trying to figure it
out. I'm asking questions. I'm asking attorneys in this field. How do I file?
I want somebody's name next to it. What do I need to do? No help.
You see what's on social media, the UFO world and their experts who are very, very brave on X and
giving advice to people like you just go forward, tell what you, you know, they wouldn't dare
prosecute your mess with you. I mean, they don't have to prosecute you to mess with you. There's
all kinds of things that have happened to you to grush to others. Um, you know? Yeah. Well,
I mean, the federal,
the government has 300,000 attorneys on payroll and that's just bureaucrats. That's not private
contractors. Everything that's said and done is reviewed by attorneys. Everything that's brought
forward publicly is reviewed by attorneys. But also, you know, the average American, I believe
one of the stats I heard was commits two or three felonies a day. I mean, they can nab you. I mean,
honestly, they can nab you for whatever. And this goes back to even me and my job, which I am so
overly paranoid of giving them even an inch like, Oh, you made a security violation. Bye-bye Dylan.
Oh, you accidentally,
accidentally sold a stuffed animal for $5 at a garage sale tax fraud. Like I don't, to be honest
with you, I don't even own stock. I will not buy stock in any company that I know has this
technology because I don't want them to come after me for insider trading. Like that's how seriously
that's how paranoid I am with them. So. Well, because you felt the boot on your neck through
all the experiences you've had after having this, these exposures. 100%. And then it gets into too,
is like,
Let's, let's build these all these people saying, Oh come forward. You'll be a hero. There is money there's book
deals. And it's like, you guys have no idea most of us are struggling to get by right now. One guy's lost the
house. Another one's not going to make rent next month. I pulled my 401k to keep a roof over my
head. I had to save up money for two years whenever I began this process, because I had a feeling which
turned out to be right. I'm going to be out. And, here we are where, Oh, Congress bring whistleblowers
forward? Oh, we're going to drain the swamp.
deep state oh we're gonna do xyz you have literal laws in place with the sec over what every single
whistleblower has done we qualify for it's not our problem the doj doesn't want to prosecute
that's on them we met our obligation and if they're not going to do it what else are we
supposed to do right there's no safety net you guys throw away your professional careers but
you're also being pressured in a lot of ways to get out but you basically throw that away to be
able to do what you feel is the right thing same with with matthew brown same with you same with a
bunch of unnamed people publicly who have been through some of this process and um i guess it's
important for our audience to know there really is no safety net it's like you have to um you're
out on your your own everybody's offering you these whistleblower protections what what good
are they david grush had whistleblower protections through the icig and and still yet they were
unable and i saw the pressures on him i saw when he was testifying that there was an
intelligence agency if he said the one wrong word and and mess just slipped up just a little bit
in his language that's why chuck mccullough was behind him during that they were ready to
prosecute internally no one ever hear about this publicly but i know it as a fact i saw it happen
that they were trying to do that so you think about all these things and the pressure's really
on like what is the benefit for people to come forward there really isn't a benefit but the
question is why do you do it still well a couple of things uh you are absolutely correct and this
is why i'm i've been so overly cautious and at this point which we'll get into i'm sure this is
coming but for example i go in i lose my job in the summer of 2024 september 30th new fiscal year
october 1st and i go in for a polygraph for a certain agency and it's a normal ci polygraph
and it happens to be redacted and it's a ci poly it's not a full scope this is do you talk to
russia are you selling secrets i don't even have a policy i don't even have a policy i don't even have
a policy i don't even have a policy i don't even have a policy i don't even have a policy i don't
passport i've been too poor to even take a vacation i mean i'm here and this has been the
first vacation i've had in 12 years to see us oh we're sorry i mean could have been something
better but the irony is is that oh well we're going to protect whistleblowers we're here for
retaliation we're here for xyz well i go into a ci polygraph and the point of a polygraph is to tell
the truth in my polygraph i'm asked what don't you want to talk about and i make it clear i don't
want to talk about my ig complaint and obviously you're being filmed on a polygraph and this person
on the computer
and they're typing back and forth and i drop that i have an ig complaint in you're like what it's
like yeah you're like what's the status i was like i have no idea i don't know anything i'm basically
out here in the dark for almost a year now he gets on his computer and he's like i'll be back he
comes back in and he laughs and he says the name of the ig and then he goes what was the nature of
your complaint what are the details and i was like you can't ask me that it's like you don't
have need to know what are you doing right and my point is is is that retaliation because i didn't
pass the polygraph i didn't fail but i'm not i'm not a counterintelligence risk so what right the
retaliation comes in all these myriad of forms if you want to see it like that they should not
be asking you that question 100 i see ig complaint is supposed to be confidential and yeah that's um
and and this goes right back to criminality and playing a game and knowing what you can get away
with and how to say things to get away with it that's all it is you're pretty sure that's their
surveillance um
phones tap things of that sort they're watching your computer um we saw it we we saw the three of
us personally we experienced that on you somebody following you to be honest with you george in my
opinion i i have just assumed and i'm pretty damn sure i'm right on this that that was mainly for
you guys because i've been operating at a point to where it's like pretty much try me i don't
really have much to lose they definitely wanted um it to be known that it was not a private
meeting between all of us i had never experienced it to that extent before but the two times
you know first time i ever met with dylan um a similar experience something happened followed
uh kind of dylan after that hard to prove that but i'm glad the three of us got to
see it that one time yeah that's annoying were there points in the
last few years that you were really encouraged man at last something's happening new york times
story december 2017 there's this program called a-tip which i'm sure you hadn't heard about and
it's a program or not. And then OSAP pops up in 2018, and we know about these documents and
investigations, and UAP Task Force gets created even before Congress officially did it. You could
be encouraged. That sounds like it's heading in the right direction. And then it seems like all
those get swatted down. I had reservations through all of it. For me personally, Dave testifying
under oath, and then me going to the IG were the only two moments that I have faith that this was
on the right track. Since then, it has been a complete joke. Are you concerned about your life
now or it's out? I mean, things that you have shared, even though it's in confidence, it's
probably known. I think, well, I think the powers that be have known that I made certain assurances
seven years ago in 2018, when I had all those events take place, losing my job, car accident,
unemployment, the VA issues. They've been,
they've been, they've been, they've been, they've been, they've been, they've been,
they've been paying attention for a while. And I made sure even back then that certain
assurances were in place. I think at this point, it's depressing. I mean, you know, I told you're
aware. I married my wife one month before I became a whistleblower. My entire marriage has been
nothing but this nonsense. Is she okay? Is she okay with this? I doubt no. I mean, she, she knows
it's true. She knows that this has been my entire government career. She knows what agencies have
done to me. She knows what I've been through. I mean, it's a joke with her and I, where
I have a master's degree, 15 years of experience. She's a very intelligent woman, but she does not
meet those qualifications. And she was making something like $40,000 more a year than I was.
And it's like, you get to a point to where it's like going full circle. You have nothing left to
lose. This may be too personal, but did she ever say, just walk away from this shit? Just walk
away. Well, I think that's why I'm here now is I have done everything I possibly can and people that
we know had told me, Dylan, walk away from it. And I have done everything in my power to try
except for this. So now this is it. So this is the, the kind of, so I was going to ask you, like,
this is the coup de grace. It's like, um, if you don't testify, it's a very bizarre choice that
they would have made. But, um, if you don't, then, then why are we doing this? Like, what do you hope,
you know, to get out of this? Uh, I don't mean to sound like the ICIG here, but what do you hope to
do? I mean, my, my point is just that it doesn't do anybody any favors. We know that from Matthew
Brown, like he threw down, he did his best. It didn't change his life. So why, why testify like
this to the American public, to George and to me, we've been talking privately for so long. Why now?
Why go public? Because I think unless you have a dramatic change in the approach of disclosure,
if our government is not going to help do it for our own nation, then you need to bring in
different tools and assets. And I'm coming this as a victim of crimes. I'm coming. This is somebody
who went through the entire process. I'm coming to this with proof that has been given in closed
doors that has been proven in classified is 100% true. I'm coming at this now. And I'm hoping that
veterans, the special forces community, I'm hoping that other whistleblower attorneys,
I'm hoping that average Joe down the street right now is going to come across this,
you know, in Iraq and I may have even helped to bring him home is going to hear this and say,
you don't do this shit. Not to Dylan, not to anybody. Yeah. Yeah. You know, you'll never work
in a, have a classification again. You'll never work in, in that whole national security apparatus.
Your whole career has been part of that. 100%. What are you going to do? We talked about it
last night. I have no idea. It is what it is. Thank God I saved up enough for me to pay my
mortgage for a while. And then I'll probably pull my 401k. And then round two,
no retirement again, no nothing. And so this is a, this is important to you enough that, uh, or
you've gotten to that breaking point where you're like, I know you can't say everything in this
interview. And I respect that. That's from a position of patriotism. You understand there's
certain things that you've been exposed to that you can't say on camera, but we can talk around
it a little bit. So I guess I'm, I'm what I'm asking is even though you know, that you can
only go this far, but you're putting your face out there, it's worth it to you.
To, to not be able to go back into, I mean, I'm making an assumption. You're not ever going to
get another government job again, unless Dave or somebody convinces our executive branch in
Congress to actually let us back in and do this the right way. But it's worth it to you as a
whistleblower. Why? Because what I have provided is true. People have been victimized. People have
committed suicide over this because of the legacy UFO thing, 100%. And more importantly, because I
guess you know, also feeling for our people, right. On this planet, we have this thing called
the sixthpectris of growing up or our secret favorite brand generation. It's really when
humanity would scheme, you know, the way to survive, to be adaptable to it. And then things
in our impact. Right. You would be actually started a lot more than an engineer with $25,000
to build this ship. Because you would just just have to hold this planet for forever and
WILL BE WANTED! But you're looking at your future right now. You're looking at a potential
planet. And then you're gearing yourself up. Right. Right now, that you just have to come
And America and our interests aren't aligned with China's interests and Russia's interests, but I would rather get ahead of this and have our government be a part of it before it comes out, because then this is going to be chaos.
Okay, but like what comes out? Like what are you talking about? You're talking about disclosure, you're talking about UAP, the reality of extraterrestrials.
I'm talking about what Carl Nell would describe as catastrophic disclosure, where information that I and others have brought forward would be released and believed and known to be true by the general public in such a capacity that our government, as we understand it, would never recover.
You think people have committed suicide over this?
Oh, 100%.
Not a fake suicide that somebody else did to look like a suicide or an actual suicide?
100%.
Because it'd make them so depressed.
Depressed and feel so alone.
Been there, done that, yep.
Not done that.
Not done that, but been there, been there, and wanted to, yeah.
You had something put in your head or medicine that made you feel that way.
Yeah, and then you go through and you're, next thing you know, you're 30 some odd years old by yourself, completely alone.
Everything you work for gone.
You have no retirement.
You're driving a broken down car that's zip-tied, picking up you in a park, and you're like, what is my life?
Let's talk about big picture.
What is it?
What does it mean?
What does this whole story mean?
Because, you know, we've been pretty far up the food chain with people who've been at it for a long time at high levels, high security clearances, worked in programs.
They all have guesses, but I don't know a single one of them that knows for sure what it is.
I will give my opinion.
This is my opinion knowing what I know for a fact.
Reading and coming into contact of information that I believe to be true.
Looking at history and looking at through.
From my perspective, I think what we are dealing with is very, very, very old.
I think old humans have wrote in those down in religious stories.
I think that it's quite clear that we have been influenced by something else.
I think Arrow has been telling the American public the truth and you have said this on Weaponized on my behalf, which is Arrow's statement, there is no scientific evidence of extraterrestrials is 100% technically true.
You have to have a control.
To have scientific proof and extraterrestrial is a very exact statement and word with an exact definition, an entity of another planet.
These things, whatever they are, are probably what are referred to as gods or demons or angels or gin or insert whatever cultural or religious perspective you have.
There are probably also extraterrestrials.
It's.
It's not a one size fits all and considering, you know, humanity has the same stories across many cultures, a flood of crafts that are in the sky, things that are coming in, helping humans, and I'm at an advantage and a disadvantage, knowing certain information that relates very clearly to things that are around the world that are related to what I know.
I don't think that's by pure coincidence or luck.
I think that the people that are in these programs know the truth to this stuff and they are looking at it through a lens of this is true, this is true, this is true, this has been here for 8,000 years, this has been here for 4,000 years, oh, we dug up this at an archaeological dig in, hypothetically, Egypt.
You know, I mentioned it to you guys last night, Lakatsky and his statement.
Um, about his faith and what it means to be human and the impact and nothing to fear, you know, Lakatsky and I are both Catholics, but I want to be clear in that it's the idea of something greater than us that is here with us and can influence us.
And Pasalka talks about this and you get into consciousness and all of these things are so correlated and that's a problem with this subject and that's why one of the things that I'm a huge proponent of going back to having our guns.
And Pasalka talks about this and you get into consciousness and all of these things are so correlated and that's why one of the things that I'm a huge proponent of going back to having our guns.
government media part of this is you have to set a foundation.
Because if you come out and you throw it all out there people are going to laugh at you they're gonna call you crazy they're going to do x y&z and you got to set a foundation, and I understand the UFO fanatics are not going to like this opinion, but this isn't for you, this is for the public, if you want disclosure, the public has to be a part of it, hence why I'm here, is to hopefully get enough people outside of the subject.
There's more to this than to just say, let's try to get this right before we get hit.
In the apocrypha.
You know, I remember it being said I'm a Catholic and I'm a Catholic now.
and come and say no we're done with this my big picture idea is it's been here for a very long
time it goes by many names it's many different things and it has an influence on all of us
you know we don't really know what they look like um you know they're so advanced to us gods sure
could be at that level they might as well be gods or so far advanced i don't think they need craft
to get here that's some kind of a bauble that's a something to get us interested look hey look at
this um that's why we maybe have so many of them they don't necessarily crash that appears to be a
crash something that's always been here i'm not entirely positive they have our best interests
at heart feels like an experiment they mess with us on a mass scale an individual scale and i'm not
sure we're ever going to understand it i tend to agree with you i have many thoughts on this and
this is one of the other things i came into knowledge of while at my work at ditra before
i lost my job
when congress passed the archives legislation where all the agencies were supposed to round up
all their documents i had a wonderful conversation on my last day and i'm sure it was just
coincidental the person in charge of collecting all of the information from ditra dealing with
extraterrestrials and as he put it quote unquote little green men happened to sit next to me at my
computer terminal and began pulling all the documents on my system and the systems in our skiff
interesting fact for you
was that he came into the old atomic energy documents from way back when and there was
intelligence and information in those that discuss what you said which is this has been
around with them and that even back then they had a similar outlook that this isn't exactly
for our benefit you know you get into and again i don't want to go to woo i want to
really avoid the woo but we're going into hypotheticals and i try to keep all options
open you're right they don't theoretically they don't have to come here i mean
we're working with neuro link we're projecting thoughts we're doing all of this dreams you
have mk ultra you have all this stuff throughout the history and all of our intelligence agencies
never get rid of that capability they only get better at and they only get better at hiding it
but if somebody's able to put a thought in your head george until you build this craft
yeah you're the one who built it but the thought came from somebody else and now you start to lose an image so what not to do to save money to make that happen if we don't save money later.
you're the one who built it but the thought came from somebody else and now you start to lose that bean.
You make a decision sometimes, you make a decision on top of things.
you need to buy bulk and now you're at risk then there's time to be strengthened by holding down the overtime.
now you start to get into places that are purely hypothetical and i'm not even saying i believe
them but it's clear there's something to this like thoughts as intruders from a non-human
intelligence having humanity do the bidding that they want without direct knowledge that it's being
asked by someone else and we're talking about that right theoretically that's a that's a possibility
100 i think on joe rogan he mentions like artificial intelligence influencing humans
who continue to create artificial intelligence and just round and round yeah the metamorphosis
philosophy that rogan talks about it's really beautiful i mean i keep all options on the table
what i know is these things are real they exist we've had them other nations have them i know that
in some way shape or form they appear in a physical sense i know that they have an interest in
people and i have a strong belief that they have an interest in certain families if you want to
call them that
you
, what does it all mean i don't know but what i do know is that as a democratic republic
and a nation that votes for our elected leaders and leaders that are supposed to provide us
information we're not fulfilling our obligation in our constitution because we're not voting with
information we are lying to ourselves what information could be released without causing
a freak out it's hard to imagine anything that a government would confirm that wouldn't lead
to five thousand follow-up questions but let's say a decision is made by this president or the next one
assuming we have another one we're gonna release some stuff we're gonna come clean up to a point
because we don't want to tell our enemies too much about where we are but what could you say
we have some technology that we didn't build it's non-human in origin as far as we know there's some
other presence here we're working on i don't know how much further you can go i think you can go all
the way up to the line of what our current capabilities are in the engineering program
and integration program i think you can go all the way up to that line i think that that line
should be discussed but i think that is up to our elected representatives to work with russia
and china and other nations that almost certainly have these same technologies
and some very well may be further along than us in some capacity
i would hope that similar to atomic weapons some type of an agreement can be made i think you can
basically disclose everything up to the line of where we are currently at to the public and then
that is for our representatives to deal with internationally geopolitically at the un i think
that is just for hardware and what these things are i think once that foundation has been set
you can then start to disclose the other things but what needs to be disclosed immediately is
the crimes i think there's a you know there's a point where you couldn't say too much about them
and um you don't want to scare the shit out of them you don't want to scare the shit out of them
you don't want to:" haha they can um dile calidad the shit out of the public but you could acknowledge
that there's something it's a legitimate mystery and then it opens up the possibility that
legitimate mainstream scientists could get into it theologians um different kinds of power
structures in the world who now know oh it it's real it's not um it's not disrespectful i'm not
going to get drummed out of academia for taking this seríaously we can get on with it now maybe
l maybe that's a way to get to the answers but i i suspect that
they are um they're always going to be at least one step ahead of us i tend to agree and you know
i get the impression that they actually control it which is conversations we've had as well
i would say one other thing though that i would really want to point out and this goes back to
history and our nation and what is very concerning to me is in the past america would bring the best
and brightest forward to do things like this whether that's computer hacking or work on this
tech creative i mean we would hire criminals and get them out of jail to come work for the fbi
i have grave concerns that in the day and age of artificial intelligence and academia
we no longer teach critical thinking and if you really want to understand this you need to get
people that think way outside the box and are creative thinkers and will look at it for what
it is and then ask every single question on what that could mean and i have a very bad feeling we
are not doing that no i mean it's like media you know so that was my start is trying to get i never
figured i i could figure out the mystery but the start was trying to get other journalists
to be interested hey this is real this is a real story you can pursue it it's honorable
uh yeah you got to separate wheat from chaff there are crazy people who make shit up but there's a
real story here the learning curve is so intense you can't do this in a week you can't read a book
okay now i figured it out
or in six months or a year or five years it takes a long time and what what reporters have time to
do that what members of congress really have the time to get their heads around it you know
yeah and that's comes back to me coming forward those are crimes you guys have seen it they
committed crimes against me our nation has done nothing about it those those agencies and those
companies are still having contracts they're still making millions of dollars the va doctors
are still treating other patients to this day no one's even sent me an apology
in fact the only person who even said thank you when it was a sideways thank you was the attorney
it's like thank you for your service to the nation young man i it's depressing what do you think's
going to happen to you after we release this assuming that we can well i uh jeremy is aware
and we talked about last night as well my intent is to hopefully go on my honeymoon finally after
all these years uh it's been unfair to my wife it's been unfair to me i want to disappear i don't
want to even look at the internet everybody can go and have their argument and they can't just go
the truth is the truth and the true speech for this itself and the truth is a light if people
want disclosure it's now up to you because this lame duck approach of we are going to make promises
and we are going to go back on them and we want to do x y and z and you're giving everything on
a silver platter and no one makes an action on it to each their own but everybody's gonna have
to answer for it at the end and i'm gonna go and disappear for a while and see how this goes and
hope that america comes to my back and to your back and to matt's back and everybody who is
testifying and has testified because at the end of the day and this is why i really hope the vets
come is you served your country your country has done this well one thing that you know i'm not
sure that congress is ever going to be able to get to the bottom of it i'm encouraged that they're
taking it seriously we know some of these members you talk to them a lot jeremy and um their interest
is sincere and they want to get to the bottom but i mean they're amateurs compared to
the people who have been keeping these secrets and i'm not sure if they'll ever succeed but one
thing they could do is establish some sort of a structure that protects whistleblowers people who
have a story to tell like you that would help them survive economically give them a safe a soft
landing spot of financial support that encourages them to tell what they know give them legal
protections there are some things that are legal protections don't stop people from breaking
into your house or cutting your brake lines or distributing health records that embarrass you
but there has to be some sort of support for people who have information who'd like to come
forward but are scared i just want to say like to our viewers because it's a very difficult
interview because we want to be able to say tell it like it is you know and just put it all on the
table but you are highly restricted on certain elements of your knowledge of the legacy uap stuff
because when you
went in to do the right thing and you went to aero and you went to the icig they immediately
classified and put into a sap a lot of that uap non-human intelligence information so our audience
only gets to hear you say i saw something these are the reprisals against me because i fell into
other information but that information i can't talk about that's a difficult thing for the
audience that to have to get yeah i i 100 understand and agree and maybe i can help
them make it a little bit easier i provided three rudimentary drawings one of which was
unclassified and the other two were immediately thrown into a sap and the two that were thrown
into a sap prove we are not alone can you replicate what you saw at least um you know of
the the triangle can you replicate for that for us today and just kind of draw that up yeah absolutely
okay i think that's that's good you know try so we're doing our best to report based upon uh with
you know the testimony you brought to us what you've done with with congress what you've done
with arrow what you've done with the icig thank you for for doing that for sure bringing yourself
forward i hope that your testimony even though it is limited right now i hope that it does
encourage other people i really hope i see you up there in congress um with authorization to tell it
like it is and that's the thing i don't know if we're going to get that for you but um you know
thank you for doing that thank you for coming forward and i hope people do support you and
other people i hope that you your testimony encourages other people to come forward if this
is as you're saying it's really fucking important it's the most important thing i think uh of our
lifetime and probably the most important thing going forward because a lot of humanity's issues
would be solved but it that is also the problem is humanity is humanity do you have a message for
anybody out there who has experienced reprisals such as you
or threats or feel scared to talk what can you tell people that that you know from your perspective
that do you have a message for for anybody that's stuck in this kind of situation dealing with
yeah give me a second because i just choked up again um i'm sorry i'm i'm so no i'm sorry to
them i'm so sorry to them this is a joke it really is i'm sorry for everybody who has tried
to do the right thing i'm sorry for all the people that sit at home and they have no one to talk to
they're isolated
they're lonely and I talked to some of them this country has done a crime
against you and I hope we are all able to find peace and I hope that you can
make your way to people that will help you get your story out it sucks this
really sucks